ici c'est la première pièce de cette
idée d'exclusion autour de la glace de
l'equilibre l'exposition ready made a
ouvert ses portes à la villa savoye à
poissy des photos par l'artiste et
plasticien philippe biancotto ce qui
m'intéressait de la notion d'équilibré
la bave les deux montré que la partie
qui paraît la plus solide qui est le
métal peut s'effondrer si la partie qui
paraît la plus fragile la glace n'est
plus là en fait fauteuil talons
aiguilles ou encore revolver des objets
mise en scène dans les différentes
pièces d'habitation de la ville 1
[Musique]
on a investi tout le premier étage de la
villa qui étaient les étages
d'habitation il y à 13 avr c'est
vraiment un dialogue entre le lieu la
photo en fait la photo est vraiment le
témoignage d'un instant de grâce là je
voulais quelque chose de vraiment sans
fioritures qui rentre directement d'une
façon frontale dans le dans le sujet qui
qui font en quelques minutes pour ce
pour certains quoi philippe biancotto a
été contacté par le centre des monuments
nationaux pour effectuer un travail
entre photos et architecture habitué à
la mode et aux portraits de stars c'est
son premier travail avec un édifice
ressent bien l'éphémère puisqu'on voit
la glace dans les objets sont fait
fondre et on se demande si au fond toute
cette construction qui nous entoure ce
chef-d'oeuvre de le corbusier n'est pas
lui même destiné à disparaître comme ça
comme de la glace l'ars est transversale
donc on peut on l'a on fait un voyage
photographique avec avec l'exposition
qui démarre aujourd'hui et
l'icône le patrimoine qu'est la villa
savoye permet un dialogue entre la
photographie et le patrimoine qui est
tout à fait pertinent l'exposition en
déambulation à travers le monument pensé
par le corbusier est accessible jusqu'au
12 décembre